no Gammons is closed I'm gonna ask for a
pig and if you do you already know who
lay keV calm while 9041 we're hanging
out uh my dude actually brought two came
to Tampa which you would describe as the
you said in the [__] that's delicious
was one of the dirtiest cities in
America she's coming scummiest yeah last
time you were here you are actually
going yeah you went out like outside of
the venue and perform in the street it
was crazy that was there that was one of
my favorite shows I've done honestly
like we took the whole crowd out I don't
know how many people came but it felt
like it was at least 50 100 people
running after me which everyone else it
was not three or four blocks we jogged
then I was like where the [__] am I
going
I'm gonna turn back we jogged back yeah
yeah no that way and then I think when
you got back in you ordered a drink at
the bar and you kept rapping for short
yeah that was that was something epic
man you know that mr. wonderful
obviously man I've been a fan since
since dr. lecktor so it's been that was
2011 right long chuckles been a while
man
how do you feel like you've grown when
it comes
in 2011 Action Bronson who was a little
bit more clean-cut you know not really
but you know what I'm saying you know
you were you were you were I was just
watching the UM cuz I wasn't sure
whether I was gonna make it in that so I
you know couldn't become total like yeah
yeah right right but how do you think I
was wrong musically I'm on this new
album and not only just on a new album
but in general I understand music a lot
better now being that you know I don't
come from a musical background I come
from a background of loving music with
not understanding it fully and just
being in the business and just spending
unheard of amount of time listening to
music and in studios - I started to
click you know you know it's like one of
these guys you know they they come out
of college they get picked up they go to
the minors for a couple of years I
figure this [__] out then something just
[__] clicks and then they become
superstar you know I'm here I'm at the
point where things are just clicking now
and it's everything's coming together I
feel like um like over your career you
know you've always been a guy who which
I feel like is something that's always
been missing from hip hop the last
decade or so you you like to take a
project and work exclusively with
somebody to keep the whether it's party
supplies or static selective yeah on the
new album I seen that Marc Ron Turner
Mark Watson
owned some pendants and production
that's the first time you work with blue
mark yeah while I step out of the
comfort zone now I guess for the debut
project cuz you can't you know my
comfort zone is wherever I'm at and
whatever I'm doing you know
have a specific comfort zone right you
know to the tune of where I'm only gonna
work with one person forever that just
happens when those situations just
happen to fall into place at the time
you know what I mean and when you build
relationships that are like friendships
right very I like building the
friendship and then from that you made
incredible music together so I just feel
like I had to step out of my comfort
zone and take a lot of chances and work
with new people you know not be bashful
is being stubborn as usual 100% and
you're on the uptown funk remix
which is like it's one of the biggest
songs in America let me tell you you
cannot play a bigger song in the club
for white people I know they lose their
[__] when that song comes everyone loses
that [__] man but you know it's number
one song in the world when [__] like
it then yeah just to be on that remix
just kind of helps definitely I was
looking for [__] like that you know I
mean like remember when Wayne really
snorted but he showed up on everything
would just jump on records in want to do
that soon and I think it's really after
that really like love right right it's
cool too cause like you know people kind
of box you and it's a super boom bag guy
I don't think that's the case though I
don't think anymore I think maybe maybe
there's ago I mean two years ago because
no one else was trying to do it now
everyone else wants to rap like that
this is true this is true and I just
think I think I think it's a bit um
working at the Yankee spring training
facility Steinbrenner field giving signs
given size you just saw Peter Gammons
wig a little star-struck and Peter
Gammons yeah can't get it done we do saw
Girardi - just came out right right
where we were standing a you were at the
we were just tell it telling the Duke
the story you actually had cheaters last
game I was that Jesus less looking left
early I did I had to leave in the eighth
inning because I had to take my mother
home and you know we were down by one
and as usual the trauma ensuing right
you know and they couldn't have been a
better script written from and Derek
Jeter and you know it's just he was just
an incredible human being who's um your
top two or three Yankees of all time
that you not necessarily all right guys
you're guys that you grew up watch
that's Julia
okay Matsui is my god you understand
like I love Kentucky muscle is my god no
obviously cheater Paul O'Neill yeah Paul
O'Neill is one of my favorites because
of it is the way place like he's like
needs a gritty [__] this little
collar guy straight up yes practicing
his swing and now feel he's [__]
killing himself he hates himself if he
misses you know straight up straight
like but you know the team's I grew up
with 96 since that sushi who came up in
that's been my guide I have a bone to
pick with you man first time me and I
have a hyung I was in Phoenix and I told
you I never Davidge before and you had
me take three days consecutive good you
got lit you blew my [__] mind now I
like it man it makes me feel I got
footage of like this and I had an
interview after that and I did I have no
idea what the [__] to the crimp I was
like yo [__] I don't even remember what
I was gonna ask a man I would even
remember Oh obviously uh you know your
profiles right and rising a lot lately
man I feel like people are some people
are like fans of yours now that don't
even necessarily listen to your music
they're just like they just [__] with
Action Bronson it's true
they watch the munchies you know [__]
that's delicious where they just love
you know your vibe or whatever there's a
lot of people that come up to me anymore
like yo you know you have great music
but we love your [__] show right like
your show is the [__] I I dig it
no matter what as long as you know as
long as you get people to entertain
somebody make somebody happy that's
really all that matters
my music isn't for everybody we all know
that I mean I would love for it to be
for everybody but not everyone has the
same type of you know humor mindset me
[__] did I have vision people who get it
get it dog you know and they really get
it yeah hundred percent um what the [__]
that's delicious
I keep hearing like vices gonna get
thrown TV network it's like the word on
the streets is I mean if not them and
have you been approached to do anything
television wise I feel like you could be
the new like you could be a full-fledged
rap star and then also be that didn't
Anthony Bourdain there's Leia as far as
I know I don't know anything about them
getting a network but I do know for sure
we're being approached by game on and
it's definitely gonna happen
I actually went to dinner with Mario
Batali last night oh well yeah actually
I think I saw that on your gram yeah and
you know we had a lot of interesting
talks but you know people seem to really
really dig this [__] they really dig the
show and a lot of people feel that
there's a room for growth in it you know
it could be much bigger than it
Oh an obvious step is and that's it's an
Internet show right now but it really
got people going what in your opinion if
you had a single chain restaurant not a
fast food restaurant but like in the
realm of the Chili's or an Apple user
which when your opinion what's what's
the top chain restaurant the action
bronze box because you know a lot of
people like or who are who connoisseurs
such as yourself might you know frown
upon such places you know what I'm
saying you know what I
I haven't been like gee I don't really
like I don't go crazy with them but body
big body loves Golden Corral the Corral
the buffet
anything buffet he loves that's like
gonna go with his but his finger choice
over ground that is the white spot every
little taste of angel cook you a stay
right in front of you again great oh you
don't know where that became from the
right true true true um I know you know
you and I are both big wrestling fans
you're more about like old-school dude
you play riff raff is a training with
Hulk Hogan man what we get thoughts when
you saw like like first of all riff raff
looks like a hold of him first
I haven't seen him act so he's holding
wasn't the best wrestler you know I mean
Hogan is not like the guy you need to be
training yeah he's just the superstar
because of his look yeah he's now like
John Cena
yeah [__] you got to train with the
Mexicans right if you want to be a good
wrestler yeah that's trained with the
Mexicans man go to Texas and trailers
Shawn Michaels's yeah oh yeah go train
was shocked voted to go to Stu Hart
dungeon
up in Calgary Alberta the - on the album
you worked with the of course activated
is Bruce by 40 who's with the ovo camp
any like have you have you and Drake had
any conversations if you guys linked up
at all no I never met him another talk
to but he had to give the okay for forty
to work with me apparently so okay you
know I know I know they [__] with me but
I don't know to what extent he's like
she shattered me out of some video I did
nursing home that's it was a great
performance at the nursing only sales
like one of the greatest videos ever
seen so you know I just you know I [__]
with Drake before
giving the okay 42 working with Metro
and obviously you know these are [__]
very talented lawyers who I'm besides I
mean I mean obviously I don't think a
lot of a lot of people would expect you
to really Brock with Drake I don't know
why it's a lot of I don't necessary
black necessary yeah that's you know
what that's what it is like if he is
putting up up it is six months if you
were diamond then you know you had a hit
record [__] like people would all
of a sudden that the the hate that that
that you know maybe you would have
getting love from earlier no it happened
man I get crazy hate already it's just
the nature of the business to put
yourself out there people are not
everyone's gonna like you and there's
mean [__] out there and they
just can't wait to tell you you scum
piece of [__] of this and now your
mother's are [__] the whole all that
type of stuff all right it comes with
the territory man you [__] you can't
take the heat you know the slogan people
still trying to jump out on stage at
your shows it hasn't happened in a
minute I'm done hoping I feel like
you've kind of set the precedent like
you could back in a lot like I hurt my
foot a little bit past couple of times I
have a little knee issue my knees
barking from all the jumps and all this
other [__] flame
I saw that you liked you have a
nine-year-old kid and he's obsessed with
WWE that's he got me back into it like
crazy I know I saw that you and your kid
like the rest of the boat
yeah you guys like like rough ounces
yeah my son both of my kids my son our
daughter
they're inside quando so they do all day
is fight I was like too like like you
know do like like low-key bootleg
versions of wrestling moves on the kid
I'm [__] around it I do MMA moves on
him I put him in submissions like if he
does something crazy to this just grab
him put his arm around his leg just stop
yeah chill out kid
chill out chill out but did not let go
right away I just saw to uh what was it
was an all-star weekend you were playing
Bieber and in pink me and he washed me
up I'm not gonna lie it's just so random
I just [__] good is this ping-pong a
Canadian thing I don't know a couple
hockey sticking and do well but the
thing is he has so much time on his
hands you know he's like Asian man with
the [__] ping-pong
I said he's like easy I told him I was
like yo you're like if Forrest Gump
rosacea you know I was like that's how
good he was he beat me didn't even break
a sorry was joking around there then he
beat two professionals at the same time
that's great
[__] telling me I'm waiting to
play him
and his man comes out to me yeah we're
just waiting for his paddle to arrive as
I got done I think um once you have the
paddle it's over yeah if he has his own
personal paddle you know it's it's
another level um a lot of people were at
least me I was kind of hoping Kool G Rap
would have been on the other mr.
wonderful album yeah I saw the tracklist
he's not on the album the guest features
are pretty which I appreciate there's
not
you're not like overdoing it with the
best features I don't have a lot against
features a lot of the only two features
that I have rapping was or mayhem Lorenz
and chance the rapper that's it and
Mayim and you're your own man that's how
big body best buddy got its get all
their big body just does what he does
when he talks that [__] he does with
he's always gonna be on my right because
mayhem is always gonna be on my records
you know that's what's up man I don't
you know go ahead you see a lot of
people doing the records I gave Gabe you
album and I got 47 features you can't
perform that not everyone is always
gonna be at you know that you're called
to come and perform the songs you got to
be able to stand on your own so and
that's why that's why I did this I could
have gotten mad features this and that I
have a coochie rap song you know I have
several of them
just one of the one of them we couldn't
clear the samples so it was like that
was the one I wanted to use but it's
gonna be heard no matter what is coming
out
whether it be on the second album or
some ships tape or something no it's not
an extinction are you done are you done
are you are you on I mean after this
album comes out a lot of times you know
people people finally get their album
out I mean obviously but these you have
sob stories but as they are you kind of
like gonna step back from putting out
free music for a while I don't know I
have no idea I you know we've been
planning on putting out blue chips 70
very low that's that's an exclusive I
haven't told anyone that so it's not
blue chips 3 so so that's gonna happen
that's that's the next project for me
and party supplies blue chip 7 and they
are now Commissioner where are we
currently working on a project so you're
gonna do a joint project without - I see
the long view is here DJ here's my
vision oh yeah that's gay yo Manny DJ
mentor DJ yo that's real talk man that's
the guy right there so party supply 7
just skipped 3 4 5 & 6
he could watch such another next level
we don't we can't even do 3 or 4 it's
already at 7 and and then an ALC project
which is gonna be how many I'm very
excited for that
yeah that's already what's your like you
know what's crazy cuz um your your my
initial when I haven't seen you unlike
like the blog like the now writes of the
world and stuff your early stuff but I
never really like I'd see you obviously
physically I remembered I'm looking at
that red hair I really didn't actually
try to explore using it so static
[Music]
and I feel like you ecstatic us it made
amazing music together what's your like
what would you would you kind of have to
me he's you know he's kind of like the
Primo to your guru you know what I'm
saying but you know obviously you've got
two projects out party supply store but
I think that just boom back you know and
why [__] I feel like anytime you would
stand and get together it's just like
nobody could I appreciate that first of
all if you know that man is from massive
right he's a boss to delete it straight
out so that's kind of like that's
following in gurus for stuff yeah but
you know he does permit me and static
will always make music - my man he
helped me out a lot in this game he was
one of the first you know one of the
first early producers like he was the
first person to put my music out to a
daughter right yeah come on that song
would serve but he is reality that was
the first time I was ever out on a block
I didn't know we were [__] ended that
she was he was like he sent it out and
then on my Twitter I just saw a
magistrate up all right well yo the
album's are now in March with mr. daga
March 24th are you doing South by
Southwest I sure AM and I saw - you're
kind of like eating healthier is that
right he trying to in the finest red
suit something else yeah you do looks
you know it's 40 pounds I'm down into
the tools I was I was like 2003 35 for a
minute so that wasn't a good idea
295 how hard is it kind of trying to do
that and being the guy that people
expect to be the not hard at all because
house discipline like last night when I
had dinner with Batali
we ate you know beautiful foods don't
eat too much and the next one you just
get back on your ship man I can't I
can't afford to do something right yeah
you got a joke I can't afford to be sick
and all this other [__] and I got a lot
of gorgeous every time you see me when
the wind blows and by the beach I have
to be gorgeous
well that's questions before we wrap
this up obviously uh I've seen I've seen
you action and sensor shows ladies love
you man what can you share with us the
most interesting
groobie situation
that is we got catfished I got catfished
before how that happened and where was
this that this was in Denver got
catfished I was with a bunch of boys we
just went over to this girl's house and
she was like she was like sending you
pics and yeah it wasn't her what it was
her but it was like 10 years ago right
and it was just one of the funniest
situations with other bin owners like
she was so hyped that we were there and
it was just her now heard of her and and
she was so hyped up within screaming at
the top of her lungs making foolish
who's just a Rhodesia addict around and
eat I'm not gonna lie I ain't
oh yeah I definitely ain't she made some
sort of Korean food oh wow it wasn't one
sort of Korea it was a wild scene and
then you guys just kind of like yo well
you know it was Ray appreciated her to
Joss fan party I mean I have another one
that comes to my what's this one I was
in New Zealand within five minutes I had
this girl in the room she pulls out and
she's like you want to get really no
idea like [__]
she [__] pulls out a bag of meth she
pulls out a [__] bag of meth and she
hits the meth in front of me that's
great hey oh yes she was here like get
the [__] on you should sit down
yeah now you little Tweaker hanging out
here I don't know why I did it in the
first place it was always like what am i
doing oh that's crazy
Oh yo that can't wait to hear the album
everything that I've heard off of it
active crazy
Terry everything yo Easy Rider one of my
favorite videos of all time thank you I
can't wait till we get some more visuals
to uh we dropped a video today and then
oh I didn't get today just now noon no I
can't wait to see that out yeah I was
here at noon so man Action Bronson my
guy let's go try to find Peter Gammons
for a [__] photo he's over there soon